as the media fixate on sideshows that'll
have zero impact on American lives
things like the mana Ford verdict or
stormy Daniels latest squall or even
recently the issue with the flag going
up or down half-mast full mast
Trump is methodically fulfilling his
campaign promises and today he delivered
on a huge one announcing a new trade
deal between Mexico and the United
States now remember what he said during
the campaign I'm going to tell our NAFTA
partners that I intend to immediately
renegotiate the terms of that agreement
to get a better deal by a lot not just a
little by a lot for our workers a Trump
administration will end that war by
getting a fair deal for the American
people and the American worker the era
of economic surrender will finally be
over and boy is it today's agreement
makes critical changes to us-mexico
trade among them
75% of auto parts will pre be produced
in North America that's up from sixty
two point five percent any vehicle
coming into the United States and 40 to
45 percent of auto parts will be made by
workers earning at least 16 bucks an
hour good stuff the deal also
strengthens intellectual property and
financial services trade protections
also improves the trade of digital
products from the start though there
were those who said it couldn't be done
trim can't Trump can't do it it's all a
bunch of bluster and when Trump raised
the ante threatening to impose new tough
tariffs on Mexico and Canada the
reaction was apocalyptic we're in the
nascent stages of a full-scale trade war
and the president simply seems to want
to escalate it's not just my state that
is involved here it's our nation it has
significant consequences for us here at
home not only just economically no
politically if you a lien eight Mexico
over the wall and over NAFTA what you
end up doing is electing this summer a
much more nationalistic
radical Mexican president who will not
cooperate well turns out hold all mo was
on board is on board with what they
discuss now just like the moving of the
US Embassy to Jerusalem the
renegotiation of the trade deal with
South Korea and Trump's standing up to
China the so-called experts have
consistently gotten it wrong under
estimating Trump you see the president
has his own team of real experts these
are people from outside the old
globalist trade establishment who were
responsible frankly for those
complicated multilateral deals that hurt
the American worker and destroyed
American industries from the start
members of trumps team like Jared
Kushner and US trade rep Bob light
Heiser were committed to leveling the
playing field and creating reciprocity
between nations that means fair deals
that will allow all parties to prosper
isn't that what we want and the
bilateral deals country to country may
indeed end up being the most enforceable
and the most beneficial for all both the
current and the soon-to-be mexican
presidents see the wisdom of bilateral
arrangements with the United States now
they'd like Canada to be part of it but
if not they're not gonna sabotage it
this is what Trump touted today they
used to call it nap that we're gonna
call it the United States Mexico trade
agreement that will get rid of the name
NAFTA has a bad connotation because the
United States was hurt very badly by
NAFTA for many years and now it's a
really good deal for both countries and
we look very much forward to it now it's
up to Canada which is sending a rep to
Washington tomorrow to either sign sign
on to the Mexico deal or I guess to try
to fashion its own bilateral deal with
the United States down the road we will
see whether or not we decide to put up a
candidate or just do a separate deal
with Canada if they want to make the
deal in simplest deal as more or less
already made now in the meantime Trump
is moving forward and as I said why
of Mexico in the United States allow
their trade relationship to be held
hostage to domestic politics in Canada
and of course Trudeau stonewalling the
strides made after a year of
negotiations are really impressive in
any objective observer if there is any
of those left would admit that tonight
and by the way this is gonna set the
benchmark for any future deals in this
hemisphere now if the reaction of the
stock market is any indication which
surge in reaction today's news Congress
should fast track the us-mexican trade
agreement and keep the Trump economy
humming and that's the angle